jean-marie le guen le secrétaire d'état
chargé des relations avec le parlement
est l'invité de preuves par 3 au moment
où la gauche
on le voit elle vit un moment entendu
mêmes survolté monsieur le guen bonsoir
bonsoir et merci d'être avec nous un
moment survolté autour de la loi macron
le gouvernement donc a dû se résoudre à
utiliser l'article 49-3 pour que la loi
pour la croissance et l'économie ne soit
pas repoussé c'était votre crainte au
dernier pointage alors qu'est-ce que
cela augure pour la suite du quinquennat
est ce la fin de tout texte d'importance
quels sont les contours de la majorité
s'il existe encore le ps au pouvoir
va-t-il continuer à se déchirer en
public sans attendre le congrès du mois
de juin on a beaucoup de questions jean
marie le guen que nous allons vous poser
avec katell prigent de l' agence
france-presse notre partenaire comme
chaque semaine avec dailymotion et avec
perrine tarneaud de public sénat donc le
49-3 le gouvernement fragilisé va
engager sa responsabilité dans un climat
qui a ressemblé ce mardi on peut le dire
un mouvement de panique
est-ce que les frondeurs qui vous ont
laissé comme seule arme kpassa genre en
force ne sont pas les vainqueurs
est ce que ce n'est pas votre échec aura
coûté je ne me reconnais pas vraiment
dans cette description je crois pas
qu'elle correspond à la situation
nous avons des moyens que la
constitution nous donne pour faire
passer des textes il y a eu autour de ce
texte un travail extraordinaire qui a
été fait depuis maintenant un mois vous
en avait parlé à plusieurs reprises plus
de deux semaines de travail en
commission plus de 90 heures de travail
en séance qui a repris le travail de
commissions plus de mille amendements
ont été adoptés sur ce texte
un travail parlementaire tout à fait
exceptionnel bon après à l'acte final
l'acte final il était de savoir alors
que tous les articles ont été adoptés
les uns après les autres positivement
donc pendant toutes ces semaines
donc la question était de savoir un
moment à nos à partir du moment où venus
se coaguler un petit peu d
des hésitations des questions d'un
certain nombre de membres de la majorité
est ce que nous pouvions est ce que nous
pourrions prendre le moindre risque sur
ce texte
donc nous avons décidé que non et puis
il nous faut aller plus vite plus fort
plus clairement les choses voilà ce
texte a été travaillé pendant des
semaines au parlement
on le présente on le vol sec alors que
justement ce texte a été pas dû
travailler avec un benoît qui s'étale
loi qui est positif pour l'économie
française pour les français dans leur
vie quotidienne
pour ces jeunes permis de conduire pour
tous ceux qui veulent prendre des cas
entre une ville et une ode on prenait
l'exemple par exemple entre rennes et
caen vous n'êtes pas obligé de repasser
par pas non plus d'accord mais c'est la
vie des français le reste c'est de la
politicaillerie qui a un intérêt pas
forcément concernés par exemple est ce
que vous redoutez maintenant que des
voix de gauche rejoigne la droite lors
du vote de la motion de censure non je
ne redoute pas alors je ne le crois pas
je ne m'imagine pas voilà simplement
c'est vrai vous avez raison de dire que
face à une droite qui avait une attitude
très sectaire sur ce texte que c'est un
texte qui est quand même commenté un peu
à droite et à gauche comme un texte
d'intérêt général qui faisait les
avancées concrètes dans la vie
quotidienne les tout pour plaire à la
droite
non pas du tout il ya des avancées
sociales tout à fait considérable je
vous donnerai le dernier exemple qui a
mérité d'ailleurs un communiqué de la
fédération cgt des transports qui
parlait d'une avancée considérable
révolutionnaire dit c'est elle sur le
fait que les transporteurs les
conducteurs étrangers lorsqu'ils frais
sur le territoire français seraient
payés au smig et non pas avec des
salaires qui sont flot de l'ordre de
l'est s'est par exemple
donc ce sont des avancées très concret
dans le sens de l'intérêt des salariés
on parle du travail du dimanche
ce sont les salariés du dimanche qui
vont pouvoir profiter d'une reconversion
vous avez été intransigeant vous n'avez
pas écouté nos propositions de
compensation non ce n'est pas exact
parce qu'ils disent oui mais c'est ce
qu'ils disent d'une façon un petit peu
formel j'allais dire je crois qu'ils
avaient décidé pour des raisons qui sont
celles de leurs postures politiques de
ne pas un certain nombre d'entre eux
d'ailleurs parce que vous savez ceux qui
étaient les principaux rapporteur de ce
texte sur les questions d'ailleurs
pressenti du droit du travail sur les
questions de l'ue dimanche et
des personnes qui venaient justement
plutôt des milieux un peu contestataire
du groupe socialiste donc je pense que
si des gens n'ont pas été à l'ecoute
c'est pas le gouvernement qui a intégré
plein amendement c'est plutôt des gens
qui sont sur une posture un peu
extérieur où la peau est pour vous
parler de la posture de l'ailé gauche du
ps est la posture défendeurs parce que
vous n'avez pas les radicaliser au lieu
d amadouer avec ce passage dans thiva
france qui n'ont pas spécialement envie
d'être amadou et je pense qu'ils sont
dans une position que je pense un petit
peu irresponsable et quand je dis un
petit peu c'est peut-être un à neuf de
miami semaine ils sont et ce qu'ils
étaient prêts totalement irresponsable
non c'est simplement je ne comprends pas
que dans les circonstances actuelles et
devant ce texte qui est un bon texte je
n'ai aucun problème pour dire et
personne n'a de problème pour défendre
que ce texte un texte équilibré pour la
société française qui fait des avancées
concrètes voir des gens qui parce qu'ils
sont plus à gauche que ce texte s'allier
avec la droite pour le faire tomber pour
mettre le gouvernement en difficulté
aujourd'hui alors que l'extrême droite
crenn et craig a une certaine dynamique
dans ce pays
la droite ne pense qu'à prendre sa
revanche qui a fait retomber par
n'importe quel moyen le gouvernement
quels que soient le fait qu'elle n'ait
pas de politique alternative
et bien malgré tout ça se retrouvaient
et prêter le flanc à des jeux tactiques
de ce côté là c'est ce que nous n'avons
pas voulu le gouvernement avance ce
texte de loi arrive un événement est en
difficulté ou leur commune en jeu mais
j'ai dit non non je non certains
voulaient mettre en difficulté le
gouvernement
le gouvernement n'y est pas il s'en sort
par cette volonté très claire d'agir
plus vite et plus fort dans le sens du
changement pour la leur en anglais alors
que certains veulent nous mettre en
difficulté que nous faisons en
découvrant en oublie un instant
défendeurs on parle de nicolas sarkozy
président de l'ump lui considère qu'il
n'ya plus aujourd'hui ni gouvernement ni
majorité que lui répondez vous tout ça
c'est de la politicaillerie il aurait
peut-être dû réfléchir à deux fois avant
de revenir à la présidence de l'ump si
la présence de l'ump l'amène à prendre
des positions qui sont des commentaires
de bas étage la real comme en gare de
base étage dire qu'il n'y a plus de
match puis on verra bien si la majorité
oui qu'il propose alternative il y en a
une on le verra il ya une motion de
censure on verra qui rallie sa motion de
censure
comment est ce que vous leur apprécié
une autre déclaration il ya quelques
instants
marine le pen et qui estime qu'une
manuel valls n'a plus qu'une solution
aujourd'hui que de démissionner et de
dissoudre l'assemblée
je pense qu'il ya un tout petit peu
d'exagération dans tous ces commentaires
pas simplement celle de la bleue peine
mais aussi de monsieur sarkozy
je ne pense pas que c'est franchement
aujourd'hui on n'a pas besoin de ça ce
qui intéresse les français devant nous
on sait pas c'est pas le procès pas les
propositions enfin c'est pas les publics
tant les commentaires de nicolas sarkozy
mais mme le pen sur y at il une majorité
il ya un gouvernement il ya des
institutions qui sont celles de la vème
république il ya une motion de censure
c'est le droit de l'opposition
est-ce que l'opposition sera majoritaire
est ce qu'elle a un projet alternatif
est-ce qu'elle a quelque chose à dire au
plan sur l'économie sur l'éducation
on verra bien vraisemblablement
malheureusement on a pu voir ces
derniers temps que lorsque monsieur
sarkozy essayer de se faire entendre
y compris dans son propre parti il n'y
arrivait pas donc est ce qu'il peut lui
nous donner des leçons d'autorité je ne
le crois pas est-ce qu'il ne je crois
que ces commentaires donc sont du
domaine de la politique politicienne et
que ce n'est pas le sujet il faut
essayer de se hausser à ce fameux esprit
du 11 janvier je reconnais en
l'occurrence qu'à gauche aussi certains
veulent nous tirer vers le bas mais nous
n'avons pas l'intention
nous avons décidé de prendre une
procédure qui permet d'accélérer
l'adoption de mesures qui sont
susceptibles de libérer l'économique de
libérer l'économie de favoriser la vie
des français et bien nous le faisons et
peu importe les commentaires d'accord
sont à l'heure de laudun je vous en
livre est un lot de commentaires tiens
je vous en place et françois hollande
mais attention en 2006 il était premier
secrétaire du ps est à l'époque et ben
c'est la dernière fois d'ailleurs que le
49-3 été utilisé par dominique de
villepin pour faire passer c'était le
contrat première embauche avait dit
rêver dit françois hollande à l'époque
c'est un déni de démocratie
c'est ce que dit d'ailleurs aujourd'hui
certains
emmanuel coste d'europe écologie donc
c'est un déni de démocratie
justement est ce que pense jean pas
cette histoire non c'est pas ça se
quitter le déni de démocratie du cpe
c'est que le texte n'avait pas été
discuté là nous sommes devant un texte
avec plus de mille amendements qui ont
été acceptées par le parlement le
parlement a joué fondamentalement son
rôle
c'est au moment du vote définitif tous
les articles ont été votés donc si vous
voulez est-ce qu'il fallait rester dans
dans l'incertitude au mont du vote
définitif alors que article par article
tout avait été fait ce qu'il fallait
prendre plus de temps est-ce qu'il
fallait revenir en arrière
non nous avons décidé d'aller en avant
et donc c'est ce que nous faisons avec
cette procédure qui est une procédure
constitutionnelle de la vème république
battu toujours par la gauche quand elle
est dans l'opposition on chasse ou moins
combattre sur jour n'ont pas toujours
bon après si vous voulez me faire dire
que c'est plutôt classique dans
l'opposition de critiquer tel ou telle
procédure parlementaire je vous le corps
en corps et bien volontiers rythme moi
c'est pas simplement je pense que les
circonstances actuelles ne peuvent pas
faire que les responsables politiques se
limite à ce niveau là j'entends que
l'opposition critique oui cette
procédure n'est pas la procédure il ya
peut-être mais est ce qu'il n'ya pas
autre chose à dire est ce qu'ils veulent
bien se hausser au niveau auquel on
prétend nous faire avant les demandes
avec la politique en faisant havre et
c'est l'économie de notre peuvent faire
avancer que vous allez faire maintenant
parce que n'est pas le droit d'utiliser
très fréquemment l'article 49-3 y
arrivera plus de grandes réformes
sachant qu'il n'y a pas de majorité
aujourd'hui pour les réformes
on va dire
libéral quoi sur le cap économique fixé
par le gouvernement
il ya plus de majorité d'abord ce n'est
pas des réformes libérales d'accord sur
le cap économique alors mais pas du tout
la l'inconvénient de cette réforme
et là plusieurs inconvénients d'abord
elle est à quelques semaines d'élections
cantonales
elle est à quelques mois d'un congrès ou
de différents congrès d'organisations
politiques et elle elle touchait à plein
de sujets très différents qui pouvait
créer des petites poches de résistance
sur chaque sujet chacun voyant nous
apparaissent alors dans la proche de
cette menace et c'est nécessaire de
toucher à tout ces verrous mais c'était
difficile
oui c'était difficile de risques alors
bien sûr qu'il ya une prise de risque si
on avait pris article par article si on
avait fait vingt loi en lieu d'en faire
une seule chacune serait passé mais nous
avons pensé que pour aller plus vite il
fallait une loi qui rassemble sur une
idée sur une cohérence qui était de
libérer l'économie de donner des
avancées sociales possibles sur des
sujets de la vie quotidienne
nous avons décidé d'accélérer leur voilà
notre la gloire c'est la cohérence c'est
l'accélération de la libération de notre
économie et de sa simplification et
d'une amélioration des conditions à leur
petit vous l'avais dit il ya un instant
jean marie le guen vous avez donc dans
votre majorité enfin à majorité
ou à côté en dehors de votre majorité
des frondeurs que y adopte une posture
il responsable est ce que pour vous le
moment est venu de réfléchir à une autre
majorité présidentielle non la majorité
elle va s'affirmer
je veux dire dans ce texte s'il y avait
une autre majorité que la majorité
actuelle
ce serait exprimé où elle s'exprimerait
dans deux jours nous avons une majorité
c'est bien parce que il y à des
personnes qui pensent que ils peuvent à
un moment ou un autre se soustraire sur
un texte de donner ce que ça change non
ça qu'on perd sa majorité
oui mais peut-être mais nous n'avons pas
perdu notre majorité la preuve c'est que
ce texte va passer vous avez peur de la
peur non nous pensions que sur un texte
positif sur un texte déterminer un
moment déterminé il pouvait y avoir une
sorte d'évaporation d'instabilité
d'ailleurs je vais vous dire très
sincèrement oui moi je pense que ce
texte serait passé simplement chez nous
bien sûr mais nous n'avons pas le droit
de prendre le risque le moindre risque
et comme nous n'avions pas une certitude
parce que il y avait des gens qui
verbalement contestait peut-être dans
l'idée de revenir sur tel ou tel point
etc
nous pouvons nous étions obligés de
mettre un terme d'un certain point de
vue à des surenchères à des postures et
d'avancer clairement mais je pense que
ce texte aurait été majoritaire alors on
ne le saura jamais mais en tous les cas
jean luc mélenchon a été reçu à l'elysée
quelle coïncidence ce mardi en sortant
sur le trottoir il a dit que c'était
l'occasion de réaffirmer qu'il lui
fallait une recomposition de la gauche
d'une gauche à côté de du parti
socialiste contre le parti socialiste
demanderait dans la société y compris ce
projet de loi d'air est ce qu'on a vu un
mouvement social
est ce qu'on a vu on nous dit si
j'entendais jean luc mélenchon d'autres
y compris parfois certains au parti
socialiste
voilà là c'est une grande question
sociale etc
on a vu des organisations syndicales
mobilisés dans des cortèges
rien rien quelques déclarations ici ou
là mais il n'y a pas de mouvement social
bon deuxièmement on a eu des élections
là qui sont des choses quand même en
situation réelle dans le doubs on est ce
que jean luc mélenchon les idées il ne
manque pas de les illustrer par des
critiques nombreuses radical est ce
qu'elles ont été entendus non qui l'a
emporté le candidat socialiste au
premier tour très largement alors que
alors que nous étions dans une situation
de très grand risque pour la gauche de
ne pas être présent au deuxième tour
monsieur mélenchon a présenté un
candidat qui a fait 2 à 3% c'est-à-dire
rien en terme de crédibilité mais par
contre un risque réel de ne pas
qualifier
adidas aussi malgré tout les électeurs
de gauche ont fait le choix et deux
qualifiés pour le second tour et au
second tour nous l'avons emporté
pourquoi parce que aujourd'hui dans la
situation nous sommes
quelle est l'alternative au parti
socialiste aujourd'hui
et bien malheureusement c'est la montée
de l'extrême droite et d'une droite
autorités alors comment vous allez phase
aller là il faudrait que jean luc
mélenchon le comprenne qu'il regarde
bien ce qui se passe dans la société que
ils arrêtent de se croire en grèce à
athènes sur le parthénon en train de
parler aux muses et qu'il regarde la
vérité de ce que pensent aujourd'hui nos
compatriotes nos compatriotes
il se pose des questions économiques et
sociales sur le chômage et ils ont
raison mais les solutions que propose
jean luc mélenchon est un certain nombre
de ses amis voire certains au parti
socialiste ne sont pas celles qui sont
portées par les salariés français et
nous pensons au contraire malgré les
difficultés que nous allons trouver des
solutions et puis il ya toutes les
autres sujets qui sont ceux de la
république qui sont ceux de la sécurité
qui sont ceux de la paix de la
coopération de la construction
européenne quand on voit comment ce
n'est pas simplement la france mais
l'europe qui est aujourd'hui attaquée et
sur tous ces sujets là il est temps que
la gauche se rassemble
parce que c'est l'avenir de la
république qui est en jeu alors
l'argument notamment de la réforme
nécessaire n'est pas le seul que manuel
valls a utilisé d'ailleurs comme vous
jean marie le guen le premier ministre
avait également mis en avant l'esprit du
11 janvier vous l'avait fait il ya
quelques instants pour demander donc que
les petites querelles passe au second
plan alors était ce opportun qu'un tel
prix jean va vous interrogez après ce
reportage de louis sybille
c'était une semaine après les attentats
l'assemblée nationale se lever d'un seul
rang et chanter la marseillaise d'une
seule voix
on promettait de ne plus faire de la
politique comme avant un mois plus tard
c'est de nouveau la cacophonie et
finalement vous retrouvez vous retrouver
de part et d'autre une forme d'union une
forme d'union
sauf qu'ils ne veulent pas changer le
pays ceux qui préfèrent ceux qui
préfèrent dire que tout va bien
la loi macron sera en fait la première
loi de désunion nationale
l'esprit du 11 janvier ne sera pas
passée par là l'arène politique a repris
tous ses droits
jusqu'à l'utilisation du 49-3 pour
éviter le camouflet le premier ministre
n'avait pas hésité non plus à rappeler
les attentats quitte à jouer sur des
peurs je trouvais il ya quelques jours
au fond que l'esprit du 11 janvier
parce que c'est ainsi le débat politique
l'actualité il s'était effacé il était
en train de s'effacer on voulait vite ou
faire tourner la page non la menace elle
est là la fracture et bien consommée au
sein même de la majorité
les frondeurs socialistes ont fait
entendre leur voix leur chef de file
benoît hamon avait clairement appelé à
voter non personne ne manquait à l'appel
de l'unité nationale et si on devait à
cette fois utilisé cet argument du
terrorisme alors à ce moment-là tous les
missiles devrait voter toutes les lois
je ne vois pas ce que la menace
terroriste à avoir avec la
libéralisation des autocars et la
privatisation des aéroports de lyon et
de nice l'unité nationale un argument
d'autorité qui ne passe définitivement
plus auprès des parlementaires
les foires et ils se foutent du monde
avec l'unité nationale élite et
nationale c'est dans le combat contre le
terrorisme
c'est certainement pas dans les mesures
économiques d'un gouvernement qui ne
fait exploser le chômage et la dette de
la france rené les entreprises en
difficile la vie des familles l'image de
françois hollande à la tête du cortège
internationale semble un peu loin les
derniers sondages marquent la fin de
l'état de grâce pour l'exécutif après un
gain de popularité spectaculaire
françois hollande perd 4 points et
descend à 30% d'opinions favorables de
même pour manuel valls qui perd deux
points pour 42% d'opinions favorables ce
tassement là d'une certaine manière il
pouvait être prévisible
il traduit moins un nouveau désaveu que
une retour à nairas pour nos forces
politique plus traditionnel
certains prédisaient la fin de l'union
nationale pour les élections
départementales de fin mars
force est de constater que plus personne
ne fait souffler l'esprit du 11 janvier
si ce n'est peut-être l'exécutif voilà
qu'à tel président de l'afp est avec le
brasseur katell vos questions à jean
marie le guen comme on vient de le voir
dans le sujet l'esprit national du 11
janvier n'est plus écouté soyons très
très objectif
nous essayons au niveau du gouvernement
et d'une très grande majorité des
parlementaires socialistes mais je crois
aussi de nombre de parlementaires pas
simplement de gauche d'être à la hauteur
de la situation et donc de répondre en
essayant de dépasser les sectarismes des
visions petit et puis c'est vrai on peut
pas dire le contraire non plus il y à
présent dans le débat politique
parfois dans les commentaires d'ailleurs
un certain nombre de forces qui nous
ramène à des choses
j'allais dire plus petites plus
classique et qui ne sont peut-être pas à
la hauteur de ce qu'attendent nos
compatriotes
voilà c'est dit je dirais gars il ya
toujours la volonté de poursuivre en
tout cas du côté de l'exécutif du côté
du gouvernement du côté du président
république de prendre les choses à une
certaine hauteur et il ya des forces qui
essayent de revenir à des petits
tchikaya est ce que comme comme ont
aussi entendu dans le sugen en appeler à
l'esprit du 11 janvier pour une réforme
économique et social s'était pas un peu
un mélange des genres bien plus crise
vous avez raison il faut il faut être
clair et être deux nous demeurons
d'orchestration de deux ans dans
l'instrumental non ben justement suivre
très attentifs à ça dans ce que nous
demande l'esprit du en janvier de ces dû
nous mettre à une certaine hauteur c'est
à dire de ne pas marquer de ne pas
oublier des différences qu'il peut y
avoir entre nous mais de ne pas
exacerber ces différences au moment où
on a besoin d'unité d'autorité on peut
marquer des différences je le comprends
je comprends que une partie des
parlementaires de droite est décidée
parce qu'ils sont
paraît-il maintenant pour aller beaucoup
plus loin
aller vers la suppression des 35 heures
bon ça c'est des positions politiques
qui sont à mon avis très radicale mais
qui sont exprimés d'autres qui disent
que ce texte était plus capable de faire
des avancées concrètes parfois limité
disaient certains parlementaires de
droite mais des avancées concrètes se
sont mis à la hauteur et on dit eh bien
soit nous voterons pour soi nous
abstenons d'autres à gauche avait des
aspirations sociales beaucoup plus forte
mais regarde aussi que dans le contexte
là ce texte était parfaitement équilibré
positif avec plein d'avancées sérieuse
pour un centre de parlementaire et qui
disent bon bah tout tous mes espoirs ne
sont pas dans ce texte mais je considère
que ce texte va dans le bon sens
et puis on a d'autres qui sont sur
d'autres arrières pensées qui sont sur
d'autres postures et qui ne comprennent
pas le besoin en tout cas quand on est
de gauche un d'être clairement au
gouvernement de gouverner la france
d'assumer des responsabilités et
d'envoyer un message de d'autorité jose
le terme d'unité nationale et de volonté
de rassembler sur une politique qui fait
avancer le pays
vous disiez tout à l'heure il ya
peut-être aussi l' approche des
élections départementales qui a joué
pour pour ce refus de voter la loi
macron comment ça va se jouer pour vous
les élections départementales parce
qu'on voit bien aussi là aussi votre
majorité est en train de s'éparpiller
les écologistes se rapproche du front de
gauche en grande majorité
on sent que le ps souhaite en difficulté
comment vous voyez ces élections vous
avez d'abord on verra bien ce qu'elles
sont et nous nous les voyons avec la
volonté d'assumer avec fierté l'action
du président la république du premier
ministre du gouvernement et l'action qui
est menée et qui est conduite pour le
redressement national pour le
redressement de la france et pour la
sauvegarde de la république
donc nous sommes vraiment tout à fait
dans un esprit combatif en temps vous
avez raison je constate avec vous que sa
a été noté dans plus de 500 quand on y
lit à une telle division de la gauche au
premier tour alors que nous pensons très
sincèrement que le parti socialiste
notamment a fait des propositions
d'ouverture ne négligent pas du tout les
désaccords mais simplement vous savez
puisque on va pas voter pour une
personne mais pour deux points vous
pourrez dire voilà on pourrait mettre un
socialiste puis l'a1 écologistes ou un
communiste ou le chemin mélenchon bond
est de rassembler la gauche avec en
respectant les divergences nous jean luc
mélenchon ce soir je fais un appel à
toute la gauche à se rassembler
maintenant c'est un peu tard puisque les
candidatures ont été déposées et je
constate que dans pour donner un chiffre
a voté les spectateurs sur ces 500 quand
on y en a au moins une centaine ou si la
gauche avait était présente au deuxième
tour vous savez qu'au plan technique je
suis un peu compliqué mais il faut faire
au moins douze ennemis des inscrits pour
pouvoir se maintenir et bien dans plus
d'une centaine de ses 500 canton le
candidat qui l'aurait emporté si la
gauche avait était présente au deuxième
tour sera était un candidat de gauche
donc par notre propre division s'est pas
sans canton pour le parti socialiste
c'est sans compter pour la gauche c'est
à dire qu'il y aurait eu des élus
communistes des élus verts qui aurait et
des élus socialistes ou des élus
radicaux qui aurait été élu mais le
sectarisme dans lequel on est à le fil à
risque de rim sectarisme de cette gauche
radicale qui aujourd'hui co secrétaire
nationale d'europe écologie les verts
un nouveau partenaire les deux premières
années du quinquennat au gouvernement
vous dit au ps
le rassemblement ça se décide pas ça se
travaille sous-entendu c'est pas au
dernier moment qu'on nous dit
rassemblons nous je crois que c'est
facile je pense je pense surtout que les
verts sont traversés par deux
orientations politiques différentes je
crois que c'est de notoriété publique et
que trop souvent le l'orientation qui
est celle de s'affronter en fait avec le
parti suisse avec une vision comme si le
combat aujourd'hui dans la société
démocratique où nous sommes c'est la
gauche contre la gauche
est ce que vous pensez qu'on pense
sérieusement quand on prend un tout
petit peu de hauteur de penser que c'est
la gauche contre la gauche l'extrême
droite ça n'existe pas la droite
revancharde et autorités coincé entre
des responsables des frondeurs les
sectarismes cela il ya une même culture
il ya une culture d'une partie de la
gauche radicale qui est je pense dans le
déni de la réalité devant les dangers
aujourd'hui de la montée de l'extrême
droite
devant le risque de la droite bon et et
parce que l' envie d'en découdre avec le
parti socialiste l'emportent sur tout
autre considération
et c'est là où je pense que dans les 48
heures vous avez tout faux car visage
que vous écrivez non mais il ya
heureusement il ya des citoyens qui sont
pas prisonniers les appareils quand ces
propositions de division été fait par
exemple dans la circonscription du 12
août et candidat frédéric barbier les
électeurs ont choisi
ils ont dit mais nous on n'est pas pour
ces candidats de la division c'est pas
parce qu'on nous promet la grèce en
france et je ne sais trop quel
radicalité hors de propos que on va
choisir pour ils ont choisi frédéric
barbier très largement et c'est frédéric
barbier qui a été élu mais maintenant
mécaniquement mécaniquement parce que si
on ne joue pas tous des experts
électoraux mais mécaniquement c'est vrai
qu'il y aura du déchet automatiquement
par l'esprit de division vous parliez de
division si justement chez les
écologistes
donc certains s'opposent à vous comme
cécile duflot l'ancien ministre d'autres
souhaitent devenir ministre jean vincent
placé ou françois de rugy mme s'en cache
plus on parle de remaniement après les
départementales possibilité d'ouverture
avec les écologistes très sincèrement
moi je souhaite que la majorité senergis
je pense qu'il est chez les verts
d'ailleurs dans toutes les formations de
gauche il faut qu'il y ait une réflexion
sur l'essentiel aujourd'hui je pense que
petit à petit les questions qui touchent
à l'essentiel vont amener à bon là on a
un petit on est un peu dans les
turbulences objectivement à travers ce
vote mais je pense que quelque part
l'esprit de de clarification va se faire
j'ai confiance parce que je pense que on
ne peut pas rester sourds et aveugles à
la réalité de la situation politique
aujourd'hui c'est je le répète c'est
quoi l'alternative au gouvernement de
françois hollande et de manuel valls
aujourd'hui c'est pas la gauche de la
gauche
je sais ce que c'est dans ce qu'il pense
ou non armés et bien j'ai peur qu'il
faut pas non mais il suffit pas moi
j'aimerais bien être aussi une star de
hollywood
enfin peut-être dans une jolie mais je
vais renoncer ou c'est notre mission la
maturité au bout d'un certain temps il
faut quand même pouvoir gérer dans la
réalité de ce pays
quand vous êtes un responsable politique
vous n'arrivez pas simplement en disant
moi je j'ai mes idées vous allez vous
suivre vous essayez de comprendre ce que
disent les gens autour de vous vos
électeurs vous les écoutez vous savez
moi je sais aujourd'hui que les
électeurs qui sont inquiets qu'ils sont
pas contents vis-à-vis de l'action du
gouvernement mais je sais où leur pouls
ou les poussent leurs inquiétudes ou se
posent leurs questions et où se posent
les tentations qu'ils peuvent être les
leurs de change et d'un vote de gauche
pour aller vers autre chose
ils vont pas vers un vote de radicalité
de gauche ils vont vers un vote qui peut
aller vers l'extrême droite qui peut
aller vers le désenchantement
mais la crédibilité vous répondait alors
à ses électeurs qui ne sont pas contents
de l'action du gouvernement parce que
l'eau qu'ils aillent bien d'abord
j'aimerais que nous ayons une pédagogie
plus forte nous à gauche et a commencé
au parti socialiste je pense que ces
divisions que vous avez pu remarquer
commenté
ni pas sont un frein profond à notre
pédagogie d'une part et à notre
crédibilité d'autre part soyons très
clairs et très honnête là dessus nous
perdons beaucoup de notre force dans nos
divisions déjà à l'intérieur du parti
socialiste et plus largement à gauche
ensuite le gouvernement a une
responsabilité
effectivement d'action et donc nous
devons obtenir plus de résultats
sur la question de la croissance sur le
réoriente la réorientation de la
politique européenne
évidemment en matière d'emploi
évidemment à une approche des questions
de justice sociale qui soit peut-être
plus ciblés plus fort on a parlé de la
question des quartiers
sur tous ces sujets le gouvernement et
travaille avec beaucoup de force mais
beaucoup d'humilité mais savons l'agenda
qui est le nôtre qui est tout à fait
confortant le remaniement n'est pas
vraiment d est ce que vous pensez quand
même que des ministres écolo vont vont
pouvoir être nommé fan gens souhaitent
écouter je le souhaitais je souhaite que
la gauche se rassemble voit là et quel
sera son et que tout gouvernement
bien sûr au gouvernement aussi bien sûr
si c'est possible faisons le mais est ce
que nous en prenons vraiment toujours le
chemin on ne sait pas quand on envoie
emmanuel quand on voit le chemin des
moines elle qu'au ski internationale du
groupe du parti écologiste dénonce un
déni de démocratie on se dit c'est
décide si des réponses automatiques 49,3
constitution vème république tout ça on
est moi je ne dis pas d'ailleurs que
c'est méchant sur son lit que la
majorité de mes cils et un constat de
décès de la majorité de 2012
oui mais jean-luc mélenchon
inspire qu'à une seule chose c'est à
faire des constate décès de notre propre
action politique
c'est son seul but dans la vie
aujourd'hui il a une obsession c'est de
voir l'effondrement de la gauche mais
encore une fois je vais pas revenir sur
ce que je vous disais pour mettre qui
jean luc mélenchon c'est une
plaisanterie aujourd'hui bien donc un
peu triste mais louise lardons qu'il te
vois entier princes attend mieux tant
mieux mais non temps mais il faut qu'ils
soient là regardons-nous avec humilité
les uns et les autres
moi je sais que le gouvernement a encore
beaucoup de choses à convaincre pour
rassembler une majorité de français
justement je ne crois pas que ce soit
dans les propositions et dans
l'orientation donnée par monsieur
mélenchon à côté d'une façon générale
par cette gauche radicale qu'on y
arrivera juste un mot sur l'avenir de la
loi macondo qu'elle va aller venir au
sénat il va repartir à l'assemblée
nationale quid de la seconde lecture
vous pourriez encore utiliser de 49 3
tout à fait et combien de fois comme ça
c'est ben autant de fois qu'il ya deux
lectures sur ce texte
donc vous êtes prêts à utiliser à
nouveau non mais je vous parlais la
presse passer d'une constitution jeu
mais bon vous savez rédiger parce que je
pense qu'il faut que les esprits un
petit peu revient à chacun mesure que
finalement il est peut-être pas
nécessaire de recourir à ces démarches
quand on peut se rassembler je pense que
à chaque fois que la gauche pourra
donner l'image du rassemblement à chaque
fois gagné en crédibilité elle gagne en
force et lin et si on veut que la gauche
avance il faut qu'elle gagne en force
merci katell merci avec perrine tarneaud
de public sénat arrive maintenant lors
du débat sur la loi macron un député ps
avait ironisé sur les divisions
socialistes qu'on vous donne
l'impression d'assister à un congrès du
ps avait lancé olivier fera en se
tournant vers les bancs de la droite ça
risque d'être encore pire au mois de
juin prochain avec le congrès véritable
à poitiers samia de sheer au congrès de
juin prochain jean christophe cambadélis
remettrait son poste en jeu alors pour
rallier des signataires le premier
secrétaire du parti socialiste fait une
démonstration de force
il a annoncé avoir déjà reçu le soutien
de deux tiers des parlementaires
socialistes
et de près de 80% des responsables
fédéraux une attitude condamnée par les
auteurs d'autres contributions
c'est une manière de faire qui datent du
siècle dernier c'est à dire que on
continue à faire les congrès comme on
les a toujours fait c'est là qu'on
essaye d'influencé d'un précieux en
alignant des signatures moi je serais
plus impressionné si on alignait des
idées et des propositions nouvelles
donc je pense que c'est une mauvaise
façon d'aborder le sujet je pense que ça
traduit plutôt un souci de garder le
contrôle de l'appareil ce qui me paraît
pas être la meilleure façon de répondre
aux attentes de nos électeurs
en tout 27 contributions ont été déposés
dont celle de martine aubry ou celle de
benoît hamon signé par beaucoup de
frondeurs dont laurent baumel lui aussi
dénoncent une tentative de jean
christophe cambadélis de verrouiller le
congrès en laissant croire que tout est
joué d'avancé
il ya un espèce d'appel ce aux autres en
disant vous savez comment ça fonctionne
il vaut mieux être dans le paquet
centrale qui est plus protecteur qui est
plus dynamique que aux marges du parti
donc ça c'est un argument est le
deuxième argument pour ceux qui seraient
encore un peu hésitants récalcitrants
c'est l'appel à l'unité on est en
situation difficile une critique rejetée
par les partisans de la ligne cambadélis
qui assume les appels au rassemblement
et j'ai pas le sentiment du tout que
jean-christophe soit dans cette attitude
là en tout cas moi personnellement je la
ressens pas du tout comme ça je crois
qu'il est plutôt dans la logique de dire
dans la période
aujourd'hui les événements connaît connu
on va pas se mentir le 11 janvier dans
la période actuelle
les résultats qui se sont passées
aujourd'hui dans le doubs qui en a
échappé à très peu une victoire du fn
l'heure n'est plus au courant et tout
simplement
l'important c'est l'unité pour l'ailé
gauche du parti le congrès reste l'une
des meilleures occasions d'infléchir la
politique gouvernementale
personne ne s'aventure pour l'instant à
dire si les frondeurs seront rejoints
par martine aubry la maire de lille
laisse planer le doute sur le camp
auquel elle apportera son soutien
voilà encore une grande inconnue qui
touche au parti socialiste
vos questions jean malgré un bon soir
alors ce qui s'est passé cet après midi
l'assemblée nationale l'utilisation du
49-3 des frondeurs qui ne désarment pas
malgré la pression ça va forcément
resurgir sur le congrès de poitiers au
moins de juin je pense même qu'on
pourrait inverser
la proposition sera que c'est le congrès
qui joue un peu sur ce qui s'est passé
cet après midi le congrès qui joue mais
ce que les fameuses posture bah je pense
qu'il ya on a bien vu que y compris
voilà ils ont sent bien seul e si vous
voulez ce texte si vous me permettez
il a été travaillé par plus d'une
centaine de députés socialistes ou font
avec de sensibilité très respirante
marty parce que martin aurait parlé le
texte de cette année ce que martine
aubry était à la manoeuvre la danse qui
se passe aujourd'hui à leur nom sur une
question manoeuvre c'est une question
c'est pas une question banale c'est
qu'il y avait deux logiques des gens qui
étaient dans le texte et dans le travail
à l'assemblée nationale quelle que soit
leur sensibilité se sont retrouvés à la
fin sur un texte qui a été très
travaillé puis ya des gens qui sont plus
extérieur j'allais dire au travail
parlementaire et qui sont arrivés avec
d'autres préoccupations tu étais des
provocations qui tiennent évidemment
plus au projet d'accord donc martine
aubry puisque michel en parle
certains disent que ça va être la clé du
congrès de poitiers vous la voyez jouer
un rôle fondamental majeur en tout cas
en fonction du conte qu'elle va décider
de rejoindre c'est à dire celui des
frondeurs ou celui de jean christophe
cambadélis martine aubry n'a aucune
envie qu'on lui prête ce rôle et vous
pensez qu'elle n'a pas envie de jouer de
rôle
j'ai pas dit ça je pense que
se vit pas dans ce rôle si en tout cas
tant mieux c'est de quel espoir ses
responsables est sûre elle fut coûté au
fond d'aucun espoir en particulier quand
il ouvrit non non mais c'est pas plutôt
en gardienne de l'orthodoxie socialiste
quand elles s'opposent au travail du
dimanche à la réforme territoriale
c'est une orthodoxie qui est aujourd'hui
ah oui je pense que dans le texte faire
d'ailleurs elle a reconnu un peu mais je
crois que les choses sont pas ce texte
n'a jamais remis en cause la
problématique du travail du dimanche il
a ouvert pour quelques milliers
peut-être quelques dizaines de milliers
supplémentaires de possibilités d'emploi
le dimanche alors qu'il ya plus de sept
millions de français qui aujourd'hui
sont amenés à travailler le dimanche
voilà et il a mené par contre des
garanties salariales et sociales
supplémentaires à tous ceux qui
aujourd'hui travaillent pour le dimanche
il faudra le répéter mais je le
répèterai attendre à du travail du
dimanche
alors que il s'agit essentiellement de
deux berges commercial dans certaines
zones mais certaines causes sociales
pour venir au congrès ce congrès de
clarification politique alors pour le
parti socialiste
moi je pense que ça doit être un congrès
de rassemblement je pense que nous
sommes à un moment où effectivement
autour du président la république et du
premier ministre pas parce que c'est
françois hollande est inconciliable
parce que c'est françois hollande et
manuel valls
et parce que la gauche est au
gouvernement elle a une responsabilité
particulière ce pays vit dans une
situation interne extérieur dans un
continent qui lui même a des difficultés
et nous devons nous situer à cette
hauteur de responsabilité est ce que le
congrès doit dire c'est nous ne sommes
pas derrière le gouvernement parce que
pas simplement par loyauté par fidélité
ça serait déjà pas mal mais par
responsabilité par ailleurs il doit
vivre sa vie faire des propositions est
positif mais pas être dans la distance
pas être sans arrêt dans la critique
dans la dent dans dans la nostalgie et
avec des discours ce soir les colonies
les frondeurs alors si on vous aime bien
aussi un discours de rassemblement des
socialistes le tout ne tourne pas autour
des frondeurs on avait prêté à la
tension monte et madame c'est pas les
fondeurs ce qui va compter c'est que le
texte de loi va rentrer en application
unique ça va changer la vie pour les
jeunes qui cherchent un terme à un
permis de conduire non mais c'est ça la
réalité de la politique
excusez moi la réalité de la politique
c'est ce qui va se passer dans la vie
des gens c'est pas le commentaire un peu
ça va mais le commentaire permanent
autour de la problématique des frondeurs
et c'est moi si j'allais de surcroît qui
vous est juste mais non celle qui
m'énerve
jauzion du débat politique qui est
ramenée sans arrêt à la politique
politicienne fin on peut en faire
restions faut en faire autre chose
quelle star droit des problèmes auxquels
sont grands mais justement il est sans
cesse qu'on prêtait attention aux
ministres de l'économie de présenter un
autre texte pour plus de flexibilité
dans les entreprises en remaniant les 35
heures
non il y à une discussion qui va être
ouverte jeudi prochain après demain
entre les partenaires sociaux et le
gouvernement manuel valls reçoit les
partenaires sociaux à matignon pour
remettre sur l'ouvragé saison le sujet
majeur par exemple prêts à en parler un
peu plus longtemps que je devais le dire
mais la fusion rsa ppe c'est à dire la
mise en activation des travailleurs
pauvres pour leur donner les moyens de
revenir vers l'emploi et d'avoir du
revenu mais aussi la question qui a été
ouverte dans la négociation dit
modernisation du dialogue social avec
différents sujets il ya un sujet
représentation des salariés dans les
petites entreprises
et il ya eu un sujet modernisation du
dialogue social dans les grosses et
moyennes entreprises voilà mais ces
sujets là ils vont être quand même si le
gouvernement peut aller plus loin dans
les réformes économiques mais plus on
inverse
vers où voulez vous avez un ordre du
jour différent l'ordre du jour du
gouvernement il est chargé ce que je
viens de vous dire réformer le rsa ppe
réformer le dialogue qui n'a pas pu
aboutir sur la modernisation du dialogue
social donné une représentation sociale
qui soit intelligente mesuré dans les
pme voilà un roman de jg acav avancer
vers la question de la formation
professionnelle pour faire en sorte que
cet apprentissage cette formation
professionnelle soient orientés vers les
salariés
voilà les sujets qui sont des sujets qui
sont au coeur de ce qu'attendent les
français
alors sans parler du congrès du ps à
poitiers mais comme vous êtes mis chargé
des relations avec le parlement est ce
que vous croyez vous toujours à
l'utilité du bicamérisme oui tout à fait
j'ai eu l'occasion de le dire et le
redire
il y a
un temps parlementaire alors après il ya
une question qui se pose c'est est-ce
que le temps parlementaire est trop long
pour faire adopter des lois dans un
monde où on demande plus de réactivité
c'est une vraie interrogation mais
question qui se pose aussi bien à
l'assemblée nationale qu'au sénat
mais pour le reste je pense que c'est
tout à fait une institut des
institutions fortes quel est l'apport
d'avoir pour vous mais l'apport du sénat
c'est un regard un peu différent qui
vient avec une distance que lui a donnée
l'histoire que lui donne pour partie son
mode de scrutin tant plus important une
certaine distance par rapport à
l'exécutif qui peut être à la fois plus
critique mais aussi plus réceptifs
bref une instance qui vit la politique à
un autre rythme et de façon différente
qui a une inspiration souvent venus des
territoires bien sûr est-ce que c'est à
claude bartolone qui est président d'une
chambre des finalement dézinguer notre
chambre
non mais claude bartolone 6 millions
iranien je sais pas tout à fait
exactement ce qui s'est vécu par son
homologue du scène apparemment entendu
mais est peut-être mais ce qu'il a
demandé précisément pour que chacun
comprenne c'est une modification de la
nature du sénat qui serait un peu ramené
avec le conseil communal législatif mais
donc une modification
voilà ça fait partie du débat politique
et notre chambre
on risque d'aller mon rôle est libre moi
je vais pas interdire surtout un membre
du gouvernement chargé des relations
avec le parlement va interdire un
parlementaire 2 1 et à au président
d'une assemblée de dire ce qu'il a à
dire
après est ce que le président du sénat
le droit de réagir vis-à-vis de produire
montrer son désaccord et faire d'autres
comme ça oui c'est moi je souhaite que
je suis pour la paix de tous les temps
dominique strauss kahn peut être une
question pour finir plus qu'une relaxe
pure et simple a été requise cet après
midi par le procureur est ce que ça rend
son retour en politique toujours
impossible non je crois que
indépendamment de cette question
je digère encore que ça pourrait avoir
évidemment des conséquences dans un sens
ou dans un autre mais je pense que la
question du retour en politique depuis
strauss kahn est absolument pas posé à
d'abord et à commencer par l'une mais la
relaxe pure et simple
c'est un fait je vais lui arrive il en
appelle beaucoup on peut dire ça comme
ça oui
1 une question quand même sur sur les
régionales puisque on a beaucoup parlé
des divisions à gauche on est on a
beaucoup parlé d' emmanuel macron
s'était dit certain handicap c'est
pourrait peut être un candidat de de
conciliation pour l'ile-de-france aux
deux personnages qui va vous livrer la
question mais je ne crois pas que ça
soit dans ses veaux votre choix entre
marie pierre de la gontrie donc et non
commerciale dit j'ai eu l'occasion de
dire et de le redire je leur dirai c'est
que marie pierre est quelqu'un avec qui
je travaille depuis très longtemps a été
ma suppléante chez souhaité qu'elles
s'engagent plus en politique justement
d'ailleurs où le plan régional
bon on il ya déjà quelques années voilà
maintenant jean paul huchon est aussi un
président et un ami que j'estime il faut
qu'on après les élections des parts
il faudra qu'on trouve une solution qui
soit la plus la plus économe et de
débats qui sont pas forts alors ils sont
poussés vous proche du pôle des
réformateurs dans le cadre du congrès
gérard collomb il ya une idée des
sessions qui se sont ouvertes sur le
sauvetage des retraites complémentaires
n'a et certains disent qu'il n'y a pas
d'autre issue que de relever l'âge de
départ à la retraite est ce que c'est
une voie et que vous soutenez pas écouté
c'est une voie d'abord qui appartient à
là on est vraiment au coeur du dialogue
social puisque ce régime est gérée
essentiellement est totalement par les
partenaires sociaux
donc je pense que la première des choses
à dire c'est que nous avons un système
qui est tout à fait stratégique celui
des retraites complémentaires il faut
qu'ils soient sauvegardés c'est la
première des choses est donc il faut
prendre les choses avec réalité et la
réalité des chiffres il n'y a pas
d'échappatoire
après vous avez un débat qui a lieu
entre certaines organisations syndicales
qui préféreraient une augmentation des
cotisations et puis d'autres qui
pourrait penser ou le patronat qui
pourrait penser que trouver différents
systèmes pour avoir
j'ai chez lui différents d'accord mais
bon escient moi je suis membre du
gouvernement et les partenaires sociaux
négocier discute qu'à un moment ils sont
totalement gestionnaire ne l'est pas
bien merci merci à vous merci perrine
mais par contre ce qui est croyez-moi
juste un point oui ils ont raison les
uns et les autres de s'affronter à la
réalité des chiffres
très bien merci la semaine prochaine
bruno le maire sur un autre invité les
périls nous serons au salon de
l'agriculture